[Musique]
le titre les soleils pauvres les soleils
propre à la ville
l'astre et majestueux
[Musique]
l'astre est majestueux ce soir
ce soir points il balaie lentement il
balaie lentement la plage de sable noir
il balaie lentement la plage de sable
noir point là la virgule ce soir
virgules
aucun nuage aucun nuage ne s'aventurent
[Musique]
aucun nuage ne s'aventure au ras de
l'océan au drame de l'océan pour
contrarier pour contrarier l'embrasement
des lieux
l'embrasement des lieux
points 2 la côte de la côte jusqu'au
piton jusqu'au piton virgules
c'est un incendie éphémère c'est un
incendie éphémère points
le spectacle est fascinant le spectacle
est fascinant point d'exclamation à la
ligne nous continuons avec les cm2 et
cm1 vous arrêtez donc la fin de l'année
pour vous une grande union avec tous les
autres donc à la ligne les hibiscus les
hibiscus virgule les toits de tôle des
maisons les toits de tôle des maisons se
pique de houssen les toits de tôle des
maisons se pique de rousseur
sous le balayage sous le balayage des
pinceaux du soleil des pinceaux du
soleil pourtant à moitié disparu je
reprends cette phrase les hibiscus
virgule les toits de tôle des maisons se
pique de housses sous le balayage des
pinceaux du soleil
pourtant à moitié disparu points les
nuages d'altitude
les nuages d'altitude sont visés et
atteint les nuages d'altitude sont visés
est atteint par les ultimes rayons par
les ultimes rayon points les lions et où
ce bouge
les lions et ours bouge virgule se
déplacent se déplace et se transforme
se déplace et se transforme en perruque
de circle perruque de cirque
saupoudrez saupoudré de rose satin je
reprends cette dernière phrase les lions
et aux houches virgule se déplacer se
transforme en père et que de cirque
saupoudrez de rosatom fin de l'activité
pour les cm2 à la ligne les soleils
pauvres se donnent souvent en spectacle
les soleils pauvres se nomme souvent en
spectacle virgule la la virgule
comme ce soir
2.7 c'est une machination de la nature
c'est une machination de la nature
virgule exceptionnel exceptionnelle
point d'exclamation un débordement
magique un débordement magique s'offrent
à qui a le temps un débordement magique
s'offrent à qui a le temps de s'attarder
de s'attarder quelques minutes quelques
minutes points
on aurait pu s'imaginer on aurait pu
s'imaginer être entré par effraction
être entré par effraction dans un album
de compte on aurait pu s'imaginer être
entré par effraction dans un album de
comptes points fin de la dictée pour les
5e 1-1 pour les seizièmes oui on
continue avec les 5e 4e et 3e à la ligne
un album de légende un album de légende
ou au d'énormes tournesol rougeoyant
illustre un album de légende où
d'énormes tournesol rougeoyant illustre
la première page
la première page pour annoncer pour
annoncer l'arrivée de la belle princesse
fille du soleil pour annoncer l'arrivée
de la belle princesse fille du soleil
virgules
vingt-et-une sari d'or vêtue d'un sari
d'or points
baptiste et annabelle ce sont les
prénoms des deux personnages principaux
de cette belle histoire ce sont des
prénoms courant donc je n'hésiterai pas
d'accord donc bâtisse et annabelle sont
eux aussi en veulent aux poupées de
lumière d'or baptiste et annabelle sont
eux aussi en veut louper de lumière
d'hommes virgule quelques secondes
qu'importe si les radiations leur
transperce douloureusement la pupille
virgules ils resteront ainsi
ils resteront ainsi sans cligner des
yeux sans cligner des yeux à attendre
yeux à attendre points fin de la dictée
pour les cinquièmes à la ligne à
attendre la rencontre du jaune et du
bleu à attendre la rencontre du jaune et
du bleu qui leur dédiera qui leur nez
dire à une seconde une seconde du rayon
vert annonciateur de bonheur une seconde
du rayon vert annonciateur de bonheur
points
le dernier faisceau le dernier faisceau
rase
enfin la surface de la mer
le dernier faisceau rase enfin la
surface de la mer points oui oui point
d'exclamation et les l'ont vu et l'ont
vu point d'exclamation
bien vu bien vu point d'exclamation
après avoir légèrement masse et leurs
yeux brûlants après avoir légèrement
masse et leurs yeux brûlants ils se sont
donné la main ils se sont donné la main
pour descendre de la roche pour
descendre de la roche points
fin de l'année écoulée quatrième à la
ligne c'est infini c'était fini virgule
rapidement l'obscurité s'installait
rapidement l'obscurité s'installait tout
alentour tout alentour poindre la lui ce
camouflet la lune
ce camouflet on ne sait où on ne sait où
bien vu lé la nuit allait régner très
noir la nuit allait régner très noir
points
la croix du sud serait probablement
visible la croix du sud serait
probablement visible et sa boîte à
bijoux presque à portée de main et sa
boîte à bijoux presque à portée de main
point il faisait frais
il faisait frais virgules
[Musique]
c'est important l'été c'était pourtant
l'été mais mais il habitait à 300 mètres
d'altitude
il habitait à 300 mètres d'altitude
[Musique]
virgule à quelques battements d'aile de
la route
forestière des eaux sous le vent à
quelques battements d'aile de la room de
forestière des eaux sous le vent point
final
marie-josée barre je vais relire le
texte de la dictée les soleils pourpre
l'astre est majestueuse ce soir il
balaie lentement la plage de sable noir
le là ce soir
aucun nuage ne s'aventure aura de
l'océan pour contrarier l'embrasement
des lieux de la côte jusqu'au piton
c'est un incendie éphémère le spectacle
elle fascinant les hibiscus les toits de
tôle des maisons se pique de rousseur
sous le balayage des pinceaux du soleil
pourtant à moitié disparu les nuages
d'altitude sont visés est atteint dans
les ultimes rayons les lions et où ce
bouge se déplace et se transforme en
père et que de cirque
saupoudrez de rose septembre les soleils
pauvres se donnent souvent en spectacle
là comme ce soir c'est une machination
de la nature exceptionnelle un
débordement magique s'offrent à qui a le
temps de s'attarder quelques minutes on
aurait pu s'imaginer être entré par
effraction dans un album de compte
un album de légende où d'énormes
tournesol rougeoyant illustre la
première page pour annoncer l'arrivée de
la belle princesse fille du soleil
vêtue d'un sari d'or baptiste et
annabelle sont eux aussi enveloppé de
lumière d'or qu'importe si l'irradiation
look transperce douloureusement la
pupille
ils resteront ainsi sans cligner des
yeux à tondre à attendre la rencontre du
jaune et du bleu qu'il en est dire à une
seconde du rayon vert annonciateur de
bonheur le dernier faisceau rase enfin
la surface de la mer
oh oui et l'on veut
bien vu après avoir légèrement masse et
leurs yeux brûlants ils se sont donné la
main pour descendre de la roche c'était
fini rapidement l'obscurité s'installait
tout alentour la lune ce camouflet on
sait où la nuit allait régner très noir
la croix du sud serait probablement
visible et sa boîte à bijoux presque à
portée de main il faisait frais
c'était pourtant l'été mais il habitait
à 300 mètres d'altitude à quelques
battements d'aile de la route forestière
des eaux sous le vent
[Musique]
alors pour l'indiquer ben c'est parti
sur près de 80 villes aux dépenses
pareil on fait les préliminaires le
quart-de-finale la demi finale et la
finale
la demi finale s'est déroulée dans saint
paul
avec plus de 300 élèves et donc pour
arriver aujourd'hui avec 120 élèves plus
cette année nous avons pour la finale
d'aujourd'hui les
madagascar et maurice donc il ya six
élèves qui représente madagascar du cm1
aussi la troisième est également promise
à bien le choix de la dictée on appris à
cette année une dame que l'on connaît
bien mais il a travaillé pour le cdh a
cependant très longtemps c'est marie je
démarre qui sera le support est à leur
expliquer c'est une écrivaine écrit pas
mal de livres et elle a travaillé
énormément avec les cdas dans beaucoup
d'écoles leur beaucoup de classe à la
réunion en finale on met toujours une
dictée quand même un petit peu plus
difficile puisqu'il faut quand même
avoir les champions mais ça se passe
bien en général
très souvent le pôle les premiers sont
toujours entre 0 faute de me forget en
faute
pas plus que sa 25e année
de comptoir régional d'autographes
quinzième année de calcul rapide mais 35
ans et 6 ans d'existence c'est aux
jeunes
le niveau au début
il faut pas se cacher c'est sa montée au
début mais à un moment donné ça diminue
et pourquoi ça diminue et tout le monde
connaît la raison c'est que maintenant
les enfants ne disent plus c'est plus la
tablette est donc on ne convenait plus
les niveaux a créé bc1 pendant plusieurs
années
donc ce qu'on est en train de faire
maintenant c'est d'essayer de voir
comment reprendre le livre comment faire
remonter le dicter les niveaux des
dictées et c'est pour cette raison que
maintenant nous faisons une infraction
dans les municipalités ont que déjà dans
six municipalités place à l'autographe
qui est une
une activité qui s'étend sur l'année
entière cette free pédagogique puisque
tous les lundis matin avant de planer
les enfants aux mines dicter à 10 heures
et ensuite on arrive en finale
la finale se passe tu as dans la salle
du conseil municipal que c'est des
communes et on fait les meilleurs élèves
de chaque classe représente leur école
et on fait une grande finale comme
aujourd'hui pareil avec que des bruits
ou essayez pour voir faire monter le
niveau en orthographe que c'est
effectivement il ya une baisse
aujourd'hui il est ainsi chargé pour
cette finale est un symbole fort
vous devez tuer un dernier salut ma
mission de la lâche cette tradition de
valorisation
le préservation de la langue française
les intéressent je voudrais aussi saluer
le travail des équipes du sida ici on
est tous les établissements scolaires
afin de faire émerger les jeunes talents
réunionnais et cela occupe un sens vous
avez un test final sur je pense de
rigueur est aussi de taille
je souhaite que cette pénurie
mais elle même où il travaille et nous
n'avons pas construit et e exemplarité
respire plus
des photos des new delhi des lieux est
donc très officieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]